overwhelmed with grief Leon O'Brien the
girlfriend of victim Jack Merritt
comforted by Jack's father at the vigil
in Cambridge Jack's mother in a gray
coat stares at the ground at 11:00 a.m.
the Cambridge community stood with them
the Market Square still and silent
remembering the lives of two
compassionate young people so cruelly
murdered Saskia Jones and Jack Merritt
was stabbed to death by convicted
terrorist Osman Khan at a prisoner
rehabilitation event there because they
wanted to help people like Khan in a
statement Jack's family said he lit up
our lives and the lives of his many
friends and colleagues and we will miss
him terribly
Saskia's family described her as a funny
kind positive influence at the center of
many people's lives let us keep silent
at the Guildhall in London less than a
mile from where the students were killed
the Bishop of London led the vigil
London's Mayor Boris Johnson and Jeremy
Corbyn silent after a weekend in which
some say they were too quick to
politicize the discourse the former head
of the parole board among the critics
it's really disappointing that's early
early on there seemed to be people
making very cheap political points out
of this which I think was disrespectful
to the victims but also factually
incorrect actually we don't yet have the
facts about this case that we need
thank you and in response to Boris
Johnson suggesting tougher sentences for
terrorists
David Merritt the father of victim Jack
wrote this in The Guardian if Jack could
comment on his death and the tragic
incident of Friday the 29th of November
he would be livid he would be seething
at his death and his life being used to
perpetuate an agenda of hate that he
gave his everything fighting against we
should never forget that pressure then
on mr. Johnson well of course I feel as
everybody does a huge amount of sympathy
for the loss of Jack merits family and
indeed for all the all the relatives of
Jack and and Saskia who who perished at
London Bridge but being her dad I've
campaigned against early release and
against short sentences for many years
Jeremy Corbyn says there's still much to
understand in the prison but this
particular individual what assessment
was made of his psychological condition
before he was released and also today
though was not about one man's hatred
but instead remembering the compassion
and hope embodied in the lives he stole
Jason Farrell Sky News